support move University in the
production of more video tutorials by
making a financial contribution or by
getting yourself one of these t-shirts
details under the support move section
on move University calm the link will be
in the description below thank you and
enjoy okay next up we got density so
what is density well before we can talk
about density we have to talk about two
other things those are mass and volume
what is mass well we mentioned it
earlier actually the first video mass
and volume actually but we talked about
how we'd figure out kind of what they
mean based on how they were measured so
mass is basically the amount of matter
something contains it's kind of a funny
definition is kind of weird it's like
well we said that matter is anything
that has mass and volume and then we
define mass as the amount of matters on
the contains it doesn't really get us
anywhere if we don't know what one or
the other is mass though is is often
measured in grams or kilograms which
kind of helps us understand what's going
on with this so mass it's um it's very
important to remember or to know that
mastic constant value and the reason why
is because it's measured on a scale or a
balance which I've kind of actually
drawn over here so if you've seen a
scalar balances like the traditional
sort of way it looks things are matte
things are masked when you basically
have a scale or a balance if you put
maybe a one-kilogram lock on this side
right one kilogram block here and it'll
it'll bring this down right if its side
is empty so we have to do we have to add
stuff over to the other side until until
the the scale is balanced right until
they're both level right and so if we
say that this thing this one block is
one kilogram anything that balances this
scale with that one kilogram is one
kilogram as well it has one kilogram of
matter so we define this thing based on
a standard and there's actually this
standard like this little this little
iridium cylinder I'll even write that
down platinum iridium cylinder that's
kept in France that's the standard for
for the one kilogram so we measure
things based on that so you can imagine
that mass is a constant value whether
you have this scale on earth or on Mars
or food oh no matter where you are one
kilogram is one kilogram because
whatever you have has to balance out so
it's a constant value measured on a
scale so the mass the mass if you take a
mass here on earth it's it's the same as
it's the same mass as it would be
anywhere else um wait however is a force
because because there's like this this
question of we know what's the
difference between mass and weight is
that weight is a force it's not a
constant value that's the same
everywhere weight is a force is actually
equal to mass times the acceleration due
to gravity the acceleration due to
gravity and it varies depending on the
acceleration due to gravity so that
basically just describing the
gravitational pool gravity on earth is
different than gravity on Pluto fact
even the gravity may be in California's
like you know in the valley in
california is different than the
gravitational pull on the top of Mount
Everest so maybe it might not be crazy
different but the point is that what I
way on earth is not what I'd weigh on
Pluto because the acceleration due to
gravity is different but whatever my
mass is here on earth my mass would be
the same on Pluto or anywhere else um so
this is an important concept and so when
you're taking the mass of something
you're actually massing it you're not
weighing weighing it would be trying to
find the weight right um but I mentioned
this here because in labs laboratories
we're always taking the massive things
even though we say you know way this or
way that we take the weight of this
you're not really taking the weight if
you're finding a measurement in for mass
you're actually massing it but nobody
actually says massing so just in case
you were curious it's just the technical
thing to say is that when you're taking
the weight you're weighing something
we're trying to find the mass your
massing it
nobody says massing okay now that we've
discussed mass let's talk about volume
volume is the amount of space an object
occupies or takes up and one of the
volume actually is is something that I
think a lot of people have learned by
the time they're like even on elementary
school middle school high school volume
is something that people pretty much
know so that should be a review as far
as that idea one thing that's important
to mention though is that is a really
really important conversion factor for
volume measurements is that one
milliliter equals one cubic centimeter
that's super super important when you
have to convert from milliliters or
leaders or kilolitres or deciliters to
any sort of cubic measurement which will
actually show an example later so what
is density well now that we talked about
mass and volume density is defined as
mass per unit volume some mass divided
by volume which of course can be
represented by D representing density
equaling m / v which is which of course
represent mass and volume respectively
sometimes you might see it represented
as Rho equals m / v + Row is just a
that's something that you'll usually see
as representing density in physics and I
think that's because the D is kind of
for a distance or displacement so you
might see row you might see D depending
on you know who your teacher is or your
professor is or whatever or what class
you're taking anyway there's this
classic question of what weighs more a
ton of bricks or a ton of feathers and
the answer is neither right some people
are inclined to say bricks over feathers
and that's not the case a ton is 2,000
pounds a ton 2,000 pounds if we said you
know without a kill a thousand kilograms
of bricks or a thousand kilograms of
feathers they have the same mass right
but what's different is the amount of
space they would take up if you have a
ton of bricks versus a ton of feathers
the ton of bricks you wouldn't need that
many bricks to get to a ton but to get a
bunch of feathers together to to have a
way to one tons that that's a lot of
feathers they would take up a lot of
space so the idea here is that bricks
are more dense than feathers they have
more mass per unit volume per amount of
space they take up so when we have this
equation density equals mass over volume
basically if you know there are three
three values right there's the density
mass volume and if you know two of them
you can find the third so this equation
here or these two in red basically if
you if you're trying to find density
it's solved for density plug in the mass
plug in the volume if those two are the
known values you can find the density if
m is unknown you solve for m so you
multiply both sides by V and you get M
equals volume times density if V is
unknown you multiply both sides by
volume and then divided by the density
or if you have this one M equals VD
divide both sides by density and you
have volume equals mass over density
right so basically you can rearrange
this equation depending on what you're
trying to solve for now the common units
when it comes to density the ones I see
most often are grams per milliliter or
grams per centimeter cubed kilograms per
meter cubed those are the ones I see
commonly but any mass unit over any
volume unit can work as density because
of the definition of density being mass
divided by volume ok now something to
pay attention to or to know is that
volume can change with changes in
temperature and pressure which means
that density changes with temperature
pressure as well if density equals mass
over volume and the temperature and
pressure differences can have an effect
on the volume then that's going to
change density right temperature and
volume don't have an effect on mass and
the way they do on on volume but if
volume changes density changes but
if assuming of temperature and pressure
are constant density is a physical
property of a particular substance so so
so if you have a constant temperature
and a constant pressure then density
density will be a constant value for
that substance and there will be
independent of the amount of substance
making density what's called an
intensive property an intensive property
is a property independent of the amount
of substance so so an example would be
if you have one gallon of water right at
20 degrees Celsius and one atmospheric
pressure versus one cup of water at that
same temperature and same pressure
they're both going to have the same
density because their temperatures
constant and the pressure is constant so
water has a particular density at that
temperature and pressure and regardless
of the amount you have whether you have
one gallon of water or one cup of water
the density will be the same in both
cases the density is the same in both
cases and so because that density
density has a property is not dependent
on the amount it's called an intensive
property the the opposite case would be
an extensive property so that's a
property that is dependent upon the
amount of substance which you know since
we're talking about density we get about
mass and volume separately each as
extensive properties you have 10 grams
of water versus 15 grams of water those
are not the same right those do not
equal each other 10 grams of water is
different than 15 grams of water so mass
is an extensive property volume is the
same way five milliliters of water and
20 milliliters of water are not the same
thing they do not equal each other right
so that's those are extensive properties
separately but when they come together
in this formula they create density
which is an intensive property ok one
question I think is really important to
ask is how does one convert between
various density units this is something
I know that people have a lot of trouble
with and best way I can do this or
explain this is with an example
and basically remind you about how one
milliliter equals one cubic centimeter
and how that's a super important
conversion factor when it comes to
density so this question says or this
problem says convert 7.13 grams per
milliliter to kilograms per cubic meter
so let's do that if we have 7.13 grams
per milliliter okay I need these grams
to become kilograms and these
milliliters to become meters cubed okay
I don't know how to go from milliliters
two meters cubed quickly so but I do
know how to take grams and turn them to
kilograms very easily I want to cancel
these grams and turn them into kilograms
that's pretty easy I can just take this
this grams I want to cancel that's going
to put grams on the bottom and kilograms
up top and then I know that there are
that kilogram kilo means a thousand
grams so there's a thousand grams in one
kilogram so that's my conversion factor
here okay so what that will allow me to
do is it'll allow me to cancel the grams
and now I basically have kilograms over
milliliters that's still not what I want
that's close because now I have the
kilograms but I still got a trend these
milliliters two meters cubed so I don't
know the direct conversion there but I
do know that I can turn one milliliter
into one centimeter cube because that
[ __ ] to the right there centimeter
cubed I know that one milliliter is one
centimeter cubed so i can multiply by
that conversion factor to cancel out the
milliliters now I have kilograms per
centimeter cubed okay we're getting
closer but now I don't want centimeters
cute i don't know how many centimeters
cubed there are in meters cubed but i do
know that there are 100 centimeters in 1
meter I put the centimeters up top here
something again cancel with it with the
centimeters down here but that's still
not right that would only cancel if I
put this centimeters up here I would
cancel with one of these centimeters I
have centimeters squared down here and
then meters that wouldn't be right
what I do though once I've set up this
conversion factor i'm going to take each
of these numbers and and their units and
cube them so i'm going to cube this
entire thing here okay so i'll take 100
cubed and centimeters cubed and that'll
become 1 million centimeters cubed on
the top now the bottom one cubed is just
one and the meters QW 1 meter cubed on
the bottom okay so what I have now is
now I can cancel out the centimeters
cubed the centimeter cube poop somebody
put that in red the centimeters cubed up
here will cancel with these centimeters
cube down here now my final answer will
have whatever units are left over which
are going to be kilograms on the top and
meters cubed on the bottom now all I
have to do is multiply all the numbers
on the top and divide all the numbers in
the bottom so 7.13 x 1 x 1 x 1 million
and once i find that divided by 1
milliliter / 1000 grams and then get
that answer / 1 good answer / 1 and what
i end up getting is 7130 kilograms per
meter cubed so I hope you can try that
with with other examples that are
similar to this hope that video is
helpful thank you for watching if you
found that video helpful be sure to
video with the like and don't forget to
subscribe if you haven't already also be
sure to share the video with anyone you
think might find it helpful thanks and
happy studying